♪ ♪
>> Tucker: O A RARE PCE OF
GO NEWS.
A FEDAL JUDGE HAS STRK DOWN
E INSANEASK MANDATE ON
PLANND TRAINS, THE MUCH
BEAGUERED PASSEER CLASS IN
THIS COUNTRYELEBRATED UPO
ARING THE NEW
WATCTHIS.
>>ASKS ARE NO LONR REQUIRED
ON DOMESTIC FGHTS FOR U.S.
AIRPTS AND EMPLOYE AND
CUSTOMS NOONGER REQUIRE TO
WE MASKS, THEYAY DO SO IF
THEY CHOE.
[CHEERAND APPLAUSE]
MASKS WIL BE OPTIONAL FORLL
CREW -
[ALAUS
>> YOU MAYEMOVE YOU MASKS.
HEERING]>> THE MK MAATE --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND ENJOY AN CELRATE.
>> Tucker: S THE MASK MANDATE
NEVER MADE SENSE ON PNES, THE
AIR ON PNES IS FILTED AND
WAY SAFER AN A RESTAURANT.
THE WHOLE POINT OTHE MANTE
S TO HUMILIATE YOUND GET YOU
TO OBEY ANDEOPLE HATED IT.
AND E AIRLINE KNETHEY HATED
IT SO ALMOST EVERY JOR CARRIERI.
BUT JOE BIDEN'S PUBLICIST WHO IS
A DEDICATED ENEMY OF HUNHAPPINEE
TEHING IN KINDERGARTEN
CLASSRM I NEW YORK CITY SAID
SHE  DISAPPOINTED IN THE
JUDGE'S RULI.
TCH.
THEDC RECOMMENDED
CONTINUING THERDEROR
ADDITIONAL TIM TO BE ABLE ASSESY
TOROTE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO THIS IOBVISLY
DISAOINTG DECISION.
>> Tucker: NO ONE BELIEVES YOU
ANORE.
ONE BIEVES THE CDC ANYMORE
U DIN YOUR CREDIBITY
ACCOT OVER THEAST YEAR BY
LYG TO US.
YOU AR A JOK
THE ONLY ONES W DON KNO
IT- AND THEY DON'T KNOIT.
AOUPLE HOURS AGO, TH BIDEN
ADNISTRATION ANNNCEDT WILLAPPEAC
LLS  TO.
"A THE CDCONCLUDES
MANDATORY ORR RAINS
NECESSARY, THE DOJ WL APPEAL
WA WHAT.
E D?
BODY WANTSHAT.
THE ONLY PEOE WHO ARE INAVOR
OF IT ARE T JOURNALISTSHO
WORK FOR THE ADMISTRION,
WHICH IS VIRTULY A OF THEM,
AND THEY A THRILLED ATHE
POSSIBILITY E AMERICAN
POPULATIONILL ONCE AINE
SUBJUGED BECAUSE THEY DESVE
IT, WAH.
>> WHAT DO W NEED TO KNOW ABOUT.
ARE WE KIN OF IN THE WILD WEST
IT'S EVE COMPANY FOR ITSELF?
>> 100
IT A MS.
MADE BY A JUD DOESN'T MEATHAT SS
ANGED.
WENOWHAT MASKS REMN VERY
OTECTIVE.
>> BASICALLY DONALD TRP IS A
DERAL JUDGE TOY.
>> YEAH, IT ABSOLUTELYEADS
LIKE DONALD TRUMP A A FERAL
JUDG
>> SO WT WE HE DONE IS WE
REVED TRAVEL MASK MANDATE
WITHN INCREDIBLYIGH LEV OF
VIRUS, AND RIGHT NOW, ASF
TODAY, ITS LESS SAFE TFIGH
IN THI COURY THAT I WAS
YESTERDAY.
>> SHE OIOUSLY ISLUELESS,
ANDHE VAST MAJORI OF
IENTIFIC EVIDEE IMASKS
HAVE SAVED MLIONS OF LIVES>> Tu]
MAS HAVE SAVEDILLIONS OF
VES!
SAYS SOME L IQ POLITICIAN WHO
HAS NER HAD A JOB
[LAUS]
SHE KNS.
THE SCIENCE.
ABOUT SCIENCE AN THE LADY YOUJUE
UNDER -- A WE'RE AAYS
ALWA HAPPY TO HAVE HER ON.
EIR POWER IS GNG AWA AND
THEYRE M!
AUGH
>>HAT WE ARE LOOKI OUTCOME
OFHESE PEOPLE, TUCKER, THEYARE Y
TO SUFFER OUT OF SPORT CE OUT
OFHEER SPORT.
WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE A SENCE DOES
T MAKE SSE, IT NEVER KES
NSE.
SCIEE EVER SHIFTG, TT IS
WHAT THEDC SPECIALES IN,MAKING O
ALONG, LIKE TY ARE ACTUALL
SIMON SAYS I THE CLD'S GAM
IT IS SAD TO M TO SEE SOANY
FLIG ATTENDANTS LEBRING
AND PEOPLE IN THEEATS BECAUSE
YOU REALIZE PEOPLE HAVEEEN
SUFFERG, FEARFUL THEY ARE
GOG TOO TO PRISON
YOU HER YOU DON'T COMPL YOU
COULD BE ARRESTED, IMANE
HAVING A FEDAL CRGE BECAUSE
YOU DO NOTEAR MASK OVER
YOUR FACE.
WE WATCHED CHILDREN SUFFER,
SPECIAL NEEDS GEKICKED OFF A
KEEP THEIR MASKSN THEIR FACE,
AS WL AS YOUNG KS, T YEARS
OLD, CRYING D SCREAMING, NOT
DERSTANDING WHY THEYRE MADE
WEAR A MASKND THIS IS
REALLY HAPPENGN AMERICA,
HAVE TVELED ALL ACRS EUROPE,
THEY RELEASED THE MK MANDATE,
THIS IS NOT SCIENCE, I I
CONTROL,HE GOVERNMT TK
WER AND THEY DON'TANT TO
GIVE IT BACK.
AND T ME,S HAPPY AS IM,S
RELIEVED AS I AM CAN GON A
PLE AND NOT WEA A MASK, I
DON'T FEEL LE THIS IS A WIN
BECAUSE WE SHODN'T BE CHEERING
ON T RTORATION OF OUR BIC
HUMAN RIGHTS.
WE SHOULD BE INFURTED AND WE
SHOULD WANTO S THESE PEOPLE
FACEONSEENCES BECAUSE GUESS
WHAT, TUCKER, THE C BROKE THE
LAW, TTS WT THE RING
SA.
IT WASNCONSTITUTIONAL.SROKE THE,
TRYI TO DO THINGSHEY WOULDHAVE .
AND REGULAREOPLE BREAK THE
LA TUCKER, THEY GO TO PRIN.
Y ARE RACHELILENY AND THE
DRUG CARTEL OPERANG OUR
COUNTRY ANYXCEPTION TO THAT
IT IS UNACCEPBLE AND I'M NOT
GOING TO CER UNTILHESE
PEOP ARE BEHIND BARS FOR WT
THEY HEONE,O THE DIGNITY OHUMANT
SIT BEHD MAS THAWE KNOW DO
NO WORK TO STOP THE SPREADF
THE VIS.
Tucr: I WLD SAY MAYBE
CANDACOWENIS OVERSTATING THE
CASE, THEN I SEE LIF EXPECTANCY
FOR AMERIC CITIZENS IS DN
DUE TO THEIR MISMANAGENT OF
COD -- N FROOVID BUT DUE
MAYBE YOU ARE RHT OVER THETARG